you know like when you're driving and
the cop lights go on and that your heart
goes but then when the cop Drives By
you're like you feel real good and then
you start driving with two hands and the
speed limit for about four minutes and
then you get back to being like
ridiculous that's how people are living
their lives right like grandma gets sick
or mom has a cancer scare or they get
sick or something and then they get
started caring about real nobody's
giving a [ __ ] about a supreme backpack
when your health isn't going anywhere
and so I just don't understand why
people are living their lives like that
and so gratitude we've got the whole
game misframed everybody's confused
people talking about Millions as like I
gotta make a million as like an entry
point and they don't even understand
that 99 of people in America don't make
400 000 a year nobody is putting on
Marathon sneakers everybody wants to be
a sprinter everybody wants it tomorrow a
lot of people taking money and instead
of investing it back into their business
buying them and that's why I've put
scrutiny on everybody who's trying to do
you know courses and pre-rolls trying to
get you pay 4 000 for this and ten
thousand and all this like all the
information is free there's a lot of
people who'd much rather much rather pay
somebody to make them feel good about
why they're not doing it Wanna Be Happy
build a life not just a business hey
it's Evan Carmichael and this channel is
created to help you overcome the number
one challenge that is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you too you've got
Michael Jordan level genius at something
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn the simple routines for
massive wealth enjoy
let me give you the secret once and for
all right here work
a lot everybody looks at the people that
made it
and none of you looked at how they got
there talk your truth create a framework
that you can follow talk your reality
think about your grandparents they
didn't have no internet they had to work
the job and go to sleep
the fact that you can work your nine to
five to pay off your debt or pay your
rent or take care of what you have to
and then you can take on your phone and
work from 7 pm to two in the morning
that's a blessing that's an opportunity
and nobody can stop you and nobody
decides but us it's crazy do you have
the humility to put in the work period
because the only people listening to
your excuses
are your loser friends my friends let's
just get to the punch line nobody gives
up about your problems people sit in
little circles with four people
everybody gassing each other up to not
do people complaining downstairs wearing
213 shoes
like get perspective what do you think
is going on in the world everybody's
pointing at everybody else without
understanding nobody's deploying empathy
here's what you don't get you lack
patience too many of you talk about
being in but you're not living it you
know why you guys aren't patient because
you want to win already
Stick it to your parents I'm trying to
become your excuse your Shield your
thing that you can point to
because if you trip and fall you guys
are worried about failing
and I'm trying to get you to point at me
and blame me that it didn't work versus
blaming yourself so that it gives you
the courage to actually start doing
but you've got to understand instead of
sitting here and dwelling and blaming
them you're in control of your own
do something with it listen some of you
been consuming this for a year or two
you watch those videos on Instagram or
YouTube you watch my Vlog or this and
that you get listen to podcasts you get
hyped
you get hyped and you're like right and
then you stop listening and you walk out
into your real life and you go back to
them you know many people sitting here
still dwelling about some dumb that
happened in 2011 it's binary this whole
thing your life is binary let me tell
you what you should focus on you need to
do something you like if I could ever
convince all of you that your
shortcomings and your detriments are
your strengths you would win you guys
want to be selfless and be good and give
back be selfish first and get your place
where you need to be the current state
of political correctness and how you
should parent how you should live what
age you should get married at like
that's all
like it's there's only one story like
yours I'm not scared of losing because I
don't allow any of you to judge me guys
you're only scared to lose because
you're worried about what other people
are going to say
my losses are my losses
rule number two develop new skills with
Tom bilyeu the real question is what is
your kung fu
you've got to figure that out
right this is a path to execution we're
talking about right now path one is
about the mindset
so what is your kung fu my kung fu is
business
I knew that I was gonna have to learn
business in order to control the
resources in order to control my art
and this is how you're going to develop
your kung fu one always be reading the
most important mathematical formula you
will ever encounter is right there I I
equals IO it stands for ideas in equal
ideas out
if you want to solve a problem in your
business that's become particularly
tricky you need to be taking in a ton of
data so that your unique mind your
unique worldview your unique life having
grown up the way that you grew up the
way that your brain is wired all of it
you will come up with ideas that nobody
else is going to come up with
but you first have to be getting that
stimulus now I doubt I have to over
preach that one to a bunch of people
that have come to a conference like this
these are literally the kinds of ideas
you want to be encountering two open
yourself up to being changed I can't
tell you how many times I've recommended
people my list of books which by the way
you can find on impact theory.com Tom's
reading list it is the 25 books any
human being that wants to excel should
read in order
and before every book say a little
prayer and the prayer goes like this
I am open to being changed fundamentally
and for the better by this book
I am open to being changed fundamentally
and for the better
from this book
you've got to go into the book wanting
it to be right you've got to go into the
book hoping that it gives you some piece
of knowledge remember everyone everyone
is your Superior in some way
and once you learn to check your ego sit
at their feet with absolute humility
and be open to their ideas especially
the one that contradicts what you
believe today then you'll get somewhere
and I've got some really amazing news
for you guys
your current skill set
has already taken you as far as it's
going to take you
if you don't put yourself on a path to
learn and very aggressively where you
are now is where you'll be in five years
the key is crossing that Chasm of skill
set
all right realize what you believe is a
choice
this is something that's really hard for
people because they think some things
are objectively true and other things
are not and that's simply a lie and
that's why
The Matrix is the perfect metaphor think
about this for a second
your brain
is locked in total darkness it never
sees light
your brain is locked in total silence it
never hears sounds
what your brain does is take stimulus
the agitation of the air and it
transmits it into chemical electrical
signals it does the same with photons
falling on your eye
But ultimately this thing that you're
experiencing the distance that you feel
from me it's all happening in your mind
there's actually two dime-sized blank
spots in your field of vision where the
optic nerve connects to the eye and yet
you don't experience it it's right in
the center
so why don't you experience it because
your brain is insanely good at guessing
what should be there and filling it in
that's when I realized my brain is lying
to me
now it may have all the best intentions
in the world but make no mistake your
brain is making [ __ ] up
and is making up a lot of
and so you've got to choose what to
believe who here has a negative voice in
their head that tells them to be careful
be safe you probably can't do it this is
all going to go wrong
now do you believe that voice to be
objectively true
okay so that voice is lying to you as
well now it has great intentions it's
trying to make sure you don't get eaten
by a lion in the bush
that doesn't happen a lot in modern
society so maybe a little less useful in
today's day and age and then the really
protective one is trying to make sure
you don't get ostracized by the group
which in years past would have meant
certain death but now
you don't need the group you can survive
just fine there's a grocery store around
every corner you can get shelter of some
kind
it may be lonely as hell but the chances
of you dying from being ostracized are
virtually zero so you've got outdated
software outdated algorithms running in
your mind
your job is to develop what I call an
OverWatch mechanism
the OverWatch is the emotionally sober
part of you
that distrusts every signal and impulse
that your brain gives you
and once you can get over that in fact
there's a great quote from Da Vinci the
greatest form of control is control over
oneself
so the reason I love Star Wars is
because it's all about mind control
but not mind control over other people
don't worry about that mind control over
yourself
being able to tell yourself these are
not the droids you're looking for
that's when this gets really powerful
all right so belief is a choice we're
gonna talk about that more be an eternal
student we've talked about that and last
one become anti-fragile
all right we're gonna go really deep on
anti-fragile so I won't belabor the
point and develop grit all right how do
you become anti-fragile this is probably
one of the most important things you
guys need to learn becoming anti-fragile
was literally the thing that changed my
life and I remember the day that it
happened
I had just started working for my two
partners
they were very smart clearly much
smarter than I
and I had built my self-esteem around
being smart and being right and now all
of a sudden I found myself these two
Incredible Minds that could process data
more rapidly than I can so I'm not going
to place a value judgment I'm not going
to get into an argument about how
valuable IQ is I will just say that a
high IQ in my opinion means that you're
processing raw data faster than somebody
else so you can run through the list of
possible scenarios for instance that
could be very helpful going into any
negotiation you've just thought through
all the possible permutations
so they made me feel badly about myself
so as you can imagine I didn't always
want to be around them and the times
that I was around them I wanted to find
some way to be right
and so we were arguing about something a
way to do something in the business and
I had an idea and then they threw out
another idea I recognized immediately
that their idea was better and yet I
kept arguing for mine ever come across
somebody who does that
I promise what's happening in that
moment is they're feeling insecure
you've triggered their insecurities and
now they're going to fight for it
because it's theirs
because if they can at least win that
argument while they may not feel smart
they may get reflected back to them that
they were smarter than you in that
moment they could convince you of
something so I had this moment of Crisis
because I actually convinced them and I
convinced them that my way was right
even though there was a voice in my head
screaming it's wrong dumbass you know
it's wrong what are you doing it was
insane I was literally heading in this
collision and I couldn't stop myself so
at the end of it I asked myself what do
I really want
because I tell people I want to get rich
but my actions say I want to feel good
about myself
and I had a moment of Crisis because I
realized I need to feel good about
myself
everybody needs self-esteem
in fact what suicide is is when somebody
no longer believes they'll ever feel
good about themselves ever again
and if that were true it's not but if
that were true suicide is actually a
reasonable option why would you want to
go on living if every day you're
miserable and there really is no way out
of that
so I knew I couldn't give up my
self-esteem I couldn't accept some weird
role where I just was always the dumb
ass sitting in the corner
right
so in that moment I realized if I'm
actually going to move towards my goals
I've got to pick something to build my
self-esteem around that's anti-fragile
now this is a term that comes from
Naseem taleb in his book by the same
name and in the book he points out
something that is resilient something
that is strong something that endures
they are all defined ultimately by their
breaking point they still break they can
just take a lot more abuse before they
break
anti-fragile on the other hand is
something that the more you attack it
the stronger it becomes
so think of it this way if I pride
myself on being smart and you tell me
I'm dumb and you put up a pretty good
case for it that's going to damage my
self-esteem
my self-esteem in that situation is very
fragile
if on the other hand you tell me that
I'm dumb and I build my self-esteem
around being the learner
now I'm going to say thank you please
tell me in what way that I'm dumb
because you will open my eyes to
something that now I can address and I
can go learn about that thing and I will
have a new skill and I can go out and
push and execute against that skill
that's anti-fragile the more you try to
tell me I'm dumb the more areas that you
point out that I'm weak the more things
you tell me I need to learn about my
eyes are open to something that if true
I'm going to go down that path and I'm
going to learn how to do that and that
is absolutely critical
all right identifying as smart as a
deadly trap as is the notion of being
right one of the most powerful things
that you could do
is become the person that admits that
you're wrong
really fast and it's crazy how much
credibility you will earn with people
simply by admitting I was wrong like 30
seconds ago I was fighting so hard for
something I was really fighting for my
position and then somebody says
something and I realize that's actually
better imagine that you're you're in the
meeting you're going die hard because
you believe it you should stand up for
what you believe and you should fight
for it but when you find somebody that
when they actually because they actually
listen and they hear holy [ __ ] like
that's actually a better idea and they
say it in real time
and not just say it but like oh my God
that's a great idea I'm totally amped
I'm on that now I'm going to be the
energy for that idea
it was crazy when I started doing that
people would actually come to me with
their great ideas because they knew if
it was right I would get so enthusiastic
about it I would give them all the
credits I did not pride myself on owning
the idea I prided myself on recognizing
the idea
and so people would keep coming to me
with these great ideas because they
wanted me to be the energy and so even
though all I would do is try and point
out whose idea it really was in like
every breath that I mentioned the idea
talking about the person who actually
came up with it I would get credit for
it because I was the one actually moving
it forward
because at the end of the day only
execution matters
you can build an amazing reputation for
yourself and one of the best ways that
this plays out is that time when you
hold steadfast and you refuse to bend
people know you're not doing it just to
argue for your own idea because you've
shown a thousand times as soon as
somebody gives you a compelling idea
that you think is better you'll move on
it
and that there's no ego in it rule
number three learn from your failures
with Dean graziosi we all screwed up and
made did things wrong congratulations
for Being Human if you're on a quest to
be a better version of you I promise
mistakes are going to be made along the
way
if you don't want to wear someone else's
name on the back of your jersey if you
want to live life to the fullest if you
don't want to see a video at the end of
your life of the woman that you could
have been that we are going to make
mistakes we are going to fail that means
that you are moving forward if you don't
have any mistakes then I'm sorry you
didn't try enough you're playing it safe
and nothing is going to change I want
you to be disturbed Within action you
want another level of life we got to
screw up we got to get out and step off
the path we got to get out of the norm
we got to get away from what's
comfortable you want to you want to take
the island you have to burn the boats
and and that Journey you are gonna mess
up you are gonna fail you are going to
do things wrong what went wrong
what didn't work
because that is the building block to
who we're supposed to be be disturbed in
a bigger way because here's what I know
if you fail of something bigger you
learn bigger lessons so I want you to
think about this I want you to take two
minutes right now and I just want you to
write down yeah you failed but what
could you have learned from it marketing
that way doesn't work talking to my
husband that way doesn't work this kind
of exercise doesn't work
but what did I learn I should mix it up
I should talk different I should listen
more I should Mark it different I need
to get more capabilities I gotta dig
back into the course those that you got
accelerated success formula got to get
back in the course project next gotta
get back in the course gotta get a coach
I don't know what it is but you'll learn
something from it I want you to take
those lessons now you can go back you
got your notes you know what we're
talking about you can go deeper on this
I want you to take those lessons
ready
you have to take the things that went
wrong identify them we have to jot down
what we can learn from them you ready
for this we want to take the things we
learned and I want you to have like this
hypothetical line drawn in the sand you
take the things you learn from the
failures and you bring them over the
line
and you leave all the other crap picture
it this way someone's I read this once
someplace and it stuck with me and I'm
going to paraphrase it now but think
about you have a house and it's all
shelves or a building with all shelves
and you're taking what serves you you're
taking the lessons learned and you're
putting them in a suitcase in your carry
them and then the place catches on fire
you let all the crap that didn't work
burn down you just carry out of the
house or across the finish line the
things you learned does that make sense
because so many of you are carrying
regrets you're carrying things that went
wrong yes some of you screwed up on
relationships welcome to Being Human
some of you screwed up in your business
welcome to Being Human some of you
didn't eat right you didn't take care of
your health you know you had diabetes
you still ate like
okay you did it you want to regret and
carry that forever or you want to leave
it in the past so you can become the man
or the woman you were destined to be we
can't carry all this from our past and
try to become who we're meant to be we
got to find a Line in the Sand and we
gotta leave it in yesterday that's how
you identify
Where You Are
and where you need to bring it with you
it's a part of the journey okay number
two
complete opposite here's the one that
nobody does they don't do it enough all
of us want to go oh this went wrong and
I didn't lose the weight and I didn't
fix the relationship I didn't launch my
business I didn't get to 100 Grand a
month and then you say well what did you
accomplish
I don't think anything right that's the
way our brain our brain wants to tell us
you screwed up on 100 things and you got
nothing done
totally not true
impossible
there are so many micro accomplishments
that you've done and we need to carry
those over with us in 2022 because
they're going to be the building blocks
that we're going to grow bigger faster
stronger on so what I'd love for you to
do right now is take a couple minutes
and I'd love for you to write down
the things the pieces the elements that
got you results that move the needle
things you accomplished I went through
the course I list I put my course up I
created a product I created a service I
got my first online sale I know what I'm
going to teach people
I got my husband and I connected in a
way I never have I started working out I
started eating better I stopped eating
eating bread or I stopped drinking too
much soda I quit cigarettes there's a
million things that could be on your
accomplishment list that you never gave
yourself credit for rule number four
stay hungry with Tony Robbins with all
the tools you've learned and the wealth
of information over 39 years almost four
decades the strategies to break people
through to help them overcome their
challenges
um if you can only have if you had to
strip them all away you can always use
one strategy or one thing to use
what would that be I wouldn't okay part
of why I'm effective is because I don't
buy that I'm always looking for more
strategy because one strategy will work
with one person not with another
um but philosophically yeah I would say
that uh the capacity to
strengthen and increase your hunger is
the one common denominator amongst the
most successful people you know um you
know Richard Branson's a good friend of
mine and Peter goober Steve when all
these guys they've never lost their
hunger most people are hungry to achieve
a certain amount make a certain amount
of money and then they get comfortable
and relax or to get a certain level of
fitness and then they relax but you know
Richard is as driven today as when he
was 16 years old starting I mean it's
like on fire and he's 65 years old
Warren Buffett is 85 years old he's as
driven today as when you know he began
the journey right and so people that
have that hunger I believe intelligence
I love people that are wickedly smart
and I work to be wickedly smart by
educating and training myself and so
forth and training my brain but
intelligence there's a lot of
intelligent people can't fight their way
out of a paper bag yeah right absolutely
hunger is the ultimate driver because if
you're hungry you can get the strategy
you can get the answer if you can't
model it you can find it so hunger
modeling would be maybe the next best
skill knowing that success leaves Clues
like why reinvent the wheel if someone
took
this plane was uh Mickey's plane who
owns the Miami Heat and owns Carnival
right I mean you can learn so much from
here like Mickey blow your mind what
this man has been able to do in his life
and so why would I go learn by trial and
error and maybe take 10 or 20 years when
I could learn from somebody in a few
weeks or a few months or a few hours
something that could save me a decade
that's what it is that's why that's why
I read 700 books in the first seven
years because I was like if somebody
takes 10 years of their life they pour
into a book right and I can read that in
an hour two or three or four why
wouldn't I so how does someone continue
to stay hungry
our Reef you know ReDiscover what
they're hungry about the best way is get
around where it's better and things will
hit you say it again get around where
it's better and things will hit you who
you spend time with is who you become so
you know when I started coaching all
these billionaires you know there's a
part of me that said I you know I I'm as
smart in certain areas as they are I
gotta step my game up it's not about the
money it's about how can I take the
invisible and make it visible how can I
find a way to add more value to other
people to such an extent where economics
are not a question whatsoever and then I
can take those economics and do even
more where I'm not there I look as money
as portable power I can leverage my
money to do things for people even when
I sleep but I love doing these for
people and I work 18 20 hour days though
but it's really nice to have the
leverage of that as well also to make
sure you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
of the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five leave your
comfort zone with Brendan burchard this
is not where High performers live
this is where people who ultimately
become very dissatisfied with life live
now it doesn't mean that you can't be
comfortable in your life there's nothing
wrong with being comfortable at some
point in your life it's just as you know
if you've studied my work that sometimes
Comfort over a period of time becomes
boring
or dissatisfied and you feel like
there's something missing and what's
missing is what we call the charge that
there is this other level of energy and
engagement and enthusiasm with life but
what I'd like to do today is begin with
this very simple challenge
and that is if you feel that you've been
here too much
and you know it because if you're here
and only here your career has flatlined
right it's you're in a plateau moment in
your career which is okay but a lot of
people hit that right they really worked
hard hard and then
they plateaued and they're wondering why
am I plateaued
this happens in athletics when I work
with high level athletes it happens in
The Fortune 50 Executives I work with it
happens with the celebrities I work with
it's not because they're not smart
they're not driven not because they're
sabotaging themselves it's not because
they're in a bad mood it's not because
the kids not because of the team
that at some point when we hit that
Plateau there's usually a reason why and
that is we started guiding our days
and we started thinking about our
Ambitions from this place
from our comfort zone and our comfort
zone
this line around it is really a line of
preferences
that's it I just you know I I don't feel
like working that hard today because you
don't have to you're already there you
right you've climbed the mountain you're
good and you're like man can I just
enjoy the view for a while and I'm like
absolutely enjoy the view love the view
set up camp on top of the mountains
shout out from the rooftops have
children start a farm you know start
making your vegetables live up there in
comfort as long as you want and then one
day you'll go
there must be some more it's just the
human ambition for growth for
contribution for deeper levels of
connection and giving that drives so
many of us I love to look at your career
your relationships your health
and suggest to you that the way out of
the comfort zone is not what you might
think most people think the way out of
the comfort zone is set a goal
they think it's have an aspiration a lot
of people think it's hope and a lot of
people what they do is they start
breaking the comfort zone a little bit
dabbling trying taking one trepid step
forward and then kind of falling back
here's what I've learned about high
performers so and this was a big
breakthrough recently uh when I was
working with a very very high level
world-class coach for sports teams and
we were talking about high performers
and what the difference is between the
guys who kind of go through the motions
comfort zone and the guys who are
working
on the field
and I believe that the reason that high
performers hit excellence
isn't because of their comfort zone but
they're in
the necessary Zone
and I know that's such a kind of a
clunky phrase I wish I had a better
phrase for it but let me walk you
through what I mean I think it's
important for all of us to find
necessary
if we are going to amplify our life to
the next level what I mean look if
you're in your comfort zone you're doing
things because it's easy it's a
preference you got good at it it's a
skill it's a knowledge it's a core
competency it's a capability you can do
and you feel good about yourself
the reason High performers stay high
performers so long is because they
believe it is necessary
to continue growing
it's necessary to put in the training
the practice it's necessary for them to
give more to serve more to contribute
more it's necessary for them to grow in
their character it's necessary for them
to deepen their relationships it's
necessary for them to feel more alive
it's part of their identity that it is
necessary to grow it's not like a hope
an idea it's not even an aspiration it's
a must it's a necessity it's a necessity
in their day it's like I was talking
recently to two NFL players great guys
Legends right really cool guys and uh
they were I just happen to be
um on some vacation and ran into them
and uh I'll show you what's really cool
as we're talking one guy was talking
about his hunger for being on the field
and he was talking about how the other
people around him who were also by the
way they're all NFL players they were
good too this guy's a legend and
he said that the main the main
difference
between what he felt like he did
and other people did is he felt it was
necessary for him to keep an edge
that's what he said
he says I have to keep that edge
I have to be
pushing myself because if I if I'm not
pushing myself
then what ends up happening is other
people pass me and it wasn't just
competitive for him because I said is
that it is this you got to be in other
people as an ego thing goes no no it
goes because Brennan they look to me
he said they looked to me
for inspiration they look to me for
leadership they look at me as a role
model
if I let off
and I fall into a comfort zone not only
will I probably not be in this that
won't last because it is so competitive
but I also won't be able to inspire the
people around me and at some point
I'll get bored
and as he was describing all that I was
like wow how many times in my life I've
heard High performers talk like that
he's not saying I pushed myself so hard
because I want to win that's not what he
said I pushed myself so hard because I'm
scared of the people replacing me that's
not what he said
pushed himself because he wanted to grow
but he also knew he was a role model
people were watching him I want you to
think about any level of growth that
you're really going to have in your life
the only way you sustain it and keep
breaking through is it's a necessary
thing for you I mean look at how many
people who start a great New Year's
ambition
it's an interest and they do they step
outside their comfort zone they go to
the gym one two three times they take
those first baby steps but they don't
stick to it because it wasn't real for
them it wasn't necessary to become
healthy
a lot of people become very healthy the
most healthy in their life after
surviving something
broke their leg
got sick saw somebody die and they said
you know what I gotta change and it
became real for them
and so I would like you to look at your
life in three areas and find your
necessary
think about first your relationships
why is it necessary for you to improve
that relationship right now
see most people they wait too late in
their life to find necessary
so your partner walks out on you
and says well I've been telling you to
get better but you never got better and
now all of a sudden oh let me make I
mean let me make better I'll get better
I'll get better I'll get better waited
too late to find necessary I said I gave
you the chances I'm out of here you
never found necessary in your mind so
you never got better in that
relationship does that make sense people
wait until tragedy they wait until the
scarcity they wait until obligation they
wait until that very last moment
because it's so much easier to be
comfortable
than to try
so I'd like to think first and foremost
for your relationships what relationship
in your life do you need to find you're
necessary in
that that like decision like I it's
necessary for me to be a better dad
because why
it's necessary for me to be a better
wife
because why
it's necessary for me to be a better
team leader
because why
if you never ask that question and
you're not clear about why it's
important to you obviously we know from
you know everything we've studied in
Psychology you lose motivation
there's no reason there's no Drive
you know there's no ambition and
expectancy that we're going to reach it
there's no motivation and so
your relationship what's necessary
now think about your career
why is it necessary for you to be
excellent at what you do
why
can you articulate it
can you journal on it today
after this video maybe you sit down
what's my necessary in my
world right now for my career
think about your health why is it
necessary for this year to be the year
you get healthier why why is it this
year right now you're gonna quit smoking
why is it this year you're gonna stop
drinking all your calories why is it
this year you're gonna stop overeating
why why is it necessary because look if
it's you're gonna fall back in your
comfort zone you're just gonna keep
smoking keep drinking the calories keep
overeating you're gonna stop working out
because it's easier it's easier this is
a path that feels so good it's the path
of least resistance but it also leads to
early death you know it also leads to
relationships that are unfulfilling it
also leads to careers that are minimal
and never scaled to the appropriate
level because no one knew what was
necessary I work harder than I need to
this it could be easy I could live Every
Day on in the Caribbean have my pina
colada as soon as it hits noon I don't
feel so guilty noon boom I'm having a
pina colada no problem I could do that
every day of my life now but you know
what I wouldn't be fulfilled you know
what I wouldn't fulfill my destiny
you know I wouldn't fulfill my potential
you know I wouldn't be here with you
guys
because for me it's necessary I work
harder I focus I develop I practice it
is a fundamental identity of a high
performer to know what is necessary now
for me to develop to grow to give to
connect rule number six build a team
with Russell Brunson the question for
right now for today is the best advice
it says can you pull the curtains back
and tell me your best advice and how I
should go about getting started as an
entrepreneur okay so this is
um this is one of the problems a lot of
entrepreneurs have right is it first if
you want to be an entrepreneur there's a
lot of things right there's a lot of
pieces that go involved in doing this
right and for some reason when we become
entrepreneurs we think we have to become
amazing at all those things I'm not sure
why we do but that's pretty Universal
for most of us right and so what happens
is we get in this thing where we're and
it's probably because we went to school
and most of us didn't like school we
struggled through school but we get done
we're like I want to be an entrepreneur
this is the platform to be
I'm gonna be an entrepreneur you're
standing on this thing like hey to be an
entrepreneur what I got to do you're
like okay first off I gotta have like
vision and then second off I gotta build
a team and then third off I gotta learn
programming and I gotta learn graphic
design they got to learn and you have
all this list of all the stuff you got
to do right and so you stand out there
you're like I gotta become an
entrepreneur I gotta learn all these
things and all of a sudden
super overwhelming right
it's a lot of things that actually goes
into that and so what I recommend for
entrepreneurs if you really want to have
success it's not so much trying to
figure out all those different things
okay the goal of the entrepreneur is not
to learn how to do every single piece in
this puzzle okay the golden entrepreneur
number one is to understand the strategy
of what you're doing
okay then number two
is to figure out the system
and number three is to build the team
okay so that's the three-step process
now I want to liken this to something
that most of us are aware of that makes
common sense so let's just say you went
to school instead of skating on the
platform of I'm going to be an
entrepreneur you said I'm going to
become a contractor I'm going to build
houses and so let's say you do that
right and so you get over here and you
stand on this platform of like I am a
contractor and I'm going to be building
houses all day right now for some reason
the rest of the world understands this
best entrepreneurs don't we think we
have to understand and learn how to do
everything but a contractor does not go
and try to figure out I gotta learn
plumbing and I gotta learn electrical
work I gotta learn how to do drywall I
got to learn how to slice them in no
right what does the contractor do the
contractors understand the strategy how
do you actually build a house what are
the things you need who are the people
you need like what's the raw materials
what's the order has to go and where it
goes first of all goes second and that's
the goal of this contract right to
understand the strategy okay then the
contractor I put together systems you
gotta get blueprints of like hey this is
what we're going to do and then he's got
to get the team assembled okay you're
the dude who's gonna lay the foundation
you're the dude who's doing the pipes
you're the guy doing the electricity
you're the person doing the roofs and he
builds people and then the contractor
gets paid the biggest bucks right so we
got to start stop thinking ourselves as
entrepreneurs have to learn everything
and look at ourselves the same way a
contractor would your goal as an
entrepreneurs not to learn everything is
to understand the strategy okay that's
why I tell people to read my books like
read the expert Secrets book read
the.com Secrets because these books
teach you the strategies what you have
to learn and understand but after you
understand the strategy then it's like
hey what's the system we're going to do
we need a funnel to make this whole
thing happen Okay the funnel hacker
cookbook for those who haven't had this
this has got like 20 different funnel
structures okay it's the systems behind
how to build a funnel today cool I know
what executing our vision we need this
funnel right here on page whatever right
now you've got the system now you've got
to build a team who are the team of
people who are going to help us execute
on this okay I know I need a designer I
need a funnel Builder I need a
copywriter I need it and you kind of
figure out who the team is you assemble
those things together and you go and you
do it now some of you guys are wondering
like Russell that's gonna be hard I
don't have the I don't have the money
for this and all those kind of things
but I want to understand it's the same
way that I started away most most
successful entrepreneurs started right I
didn't build click funnels just off of
like me being a genius because I'm not
ask my team like there's very few things
I'm good right but what am I good at I
understand the strategy okay I put
together systems make it happen and we
built a team of amazing people okay just
sitting in this room right now I've got
people here who Drive traffic who do our
Instagram who do our video who do our
like uh copy we do our like all the all
the people I've assembled but I don't
know how to do any of the pieces I don't
know how to go and lay the piping or the
electricity or any of those things right
I just understand the overarching
strategy so if you use the entrepreneur
that's your number one Focus okay so if
you're looking like let me pull back the
curtains it's like hey guess what
Russell's not actually Superman he's not
actually that good at many things the
one thing he's good at understanding the
strategy of where we're trying to go
with our vision okay and we understand
that like that's the key that's your job
as an entrepreneur understand the
strategy okay think about Steve Jobs and
the greatest entrepreneurs of Our
Lifetime right with Steve Jobs a
programmer no was he a designer no he
couldn't do any of those things right
but he had the vision this is what I
want this is a strategy okay you start
putting together a team you got Wozniak
you guys other people build out the team
and Boom Out came Apple okay same
thing's gonna be true for you guys um
understand that that's your job as an
entrepreneurs understand the strategy
create the systems and build the team
and that's how you start scaling and
growing an actual company rule number
seven don't compare your s to other
people with Guru gopal Das the one thing
that I've learned
I've learned our lives are so different
our situations are so different our
backgrounds are so different our
upbringing is so different the Journey
of our life up until now for each one of
us is so different compared to somebody
else and therefore it's so important
that we don't judge our own life all the
lives of others by comparing them with
someone else's life here's an example
if Mr a can Sprint a distance of 10
kilometers in one hour whereas Mr B
covers the same distance in one and a
half hour which one of the two would you
call faster and healthier the answer
obviously would be Mr a
now what if I tell you that Mr a had a
prepared track to run on when Mr B
written by walking on a Sandy path I
think our answer will not change and we
probably think that Mr B is fitter and
let's say we come to know that actually
Mr a is 75 years old while B is only 20.
here we go our answer changes again and
we now think that the 75 year old Mr a
is healthier guess what Mr aov 60 kg
where is Mr B 125 kg which makes it
really hard for him to run who do you
think did well oh my goodness now we
correct ourselves again as we favor Mr B
the more we get to know about the
strengths and limitations of Mr A and B
respectively
our opinions and judgments about who is
better keep changing and isn't life like
that as well guys we form opinions about
others so quickly so hastily so
impulsively so superficially without
knowing much about them or their
situations we end up judging people
labeling people and miss out on
connecting to and encouraging the
immense potential that they may have
life is not the same for all some may
not be as talented as others but may get
better opportunities and thus scale up
very fast whereas others despite being
super talented keep struggling just to
make the ends meet
some may have more resources whereas
others can't find any source to fall
back on
each one has different problems and so
no one solution can work for all just
like one size of clothing doesn't fit
all so do not judge others Journey
without knowing more do not judge your
own life by looking at someone else's or
comparing your situation with someone
else's you are you and
your life is your life and theirs is
theirs don't take inspiration from their
journey in a way that you can enrich
yours and always remember life is the
most difficult exam many people fail
because they try to copy others not
realizing that everyone has a different
question paper rule number eight be
desperate with Ed my light people avoid
being desperate think of the fact they
come here tonight and they're down
they're not where they want to be
financially the relationships aren't
what they want maybe they're in a
desperate place and you might think
that's a negative thing but when you're
in a desperate place you take the best
actions desperation is a great place to
be those you that are achieving one of
the reasons the achievement is slowed
down is you've allowed yourself to feel
less desperate when you are broke and
starting your business or when you are
brand new in your relationship and you
were desperate to get her to love you or
desperate to get him to love you you
took massive big action how many of you
are moms in the room raise your hand you
mobs if you woke up tomorrow morning and
your baby wasn't in their bed
would you be desperate right away yes or
no
Big Time desperation you wouldn't be
thinking about what you need to do you'd
be acting wouldn't you you'd immediately
make the decision you take Massive
Action you'd search the house you'd go
into the street would you worry if your
makeup was on right how you looked what
people thought about you you wouldn't
would you have to have the perfect plan
to go find your baby that's missing you
wouldn't need any of that because you
were desperate
so when you remove desperation all this
[ __ ] creeps into your life where you
think you have to have the perfect plan
and look the perfect way and have the
perfect thoughts and be all sin and
perfect what you need is to be desperate
what you need is to get after it and I
want you to get desperate to make that
decision why because our obsessions
become our possessions what you obsess
about most regularly you will eventually
possess in your life the challenge for
most people sisters and brothers is that
we obsess on the things we're fearful of
what we don't have what we're worried
about and then we end up possessing
those things over and over again rather
than programming ourselves to become
obsessed with what we want what our
dreams are what we believe we deserve
when we become obsessed about those
things long term we end up possessing
those things can I get an amen for that
yes rule number nine stay focused with
Grant Cardone I'm going to share with
you three things that I do every day to
stay focused number one
I need meaningful goals I was talking to
the to my friends they're like how do
you set realistic goals I'm like don't
set realistic goals set meaningful
meaningful game-changing okay uh
Nothing's Gonna keep your focus if it's
not meaningful right so like if if I
tell you right now hey uh there's uh ten
dollars
and your goal is ten dollars
uh that's not meaningful enough if it's
a hundred dollars most people are like
they're not going to do a whole bunch to
go get a hundred dollars but what if I
made this 100 million
foreign
okay even though it's impossible
I'll promise you I'll promise you if I
sit down with Johnny and say Johnny I'm
gonna show you how to get a hundred
million dollars illegally
in your lifetime
if the payoff is big enough meaningful
significant game changing this is why
people give up on their goals they give
up on their goals because they're not
meaningful they're not significant
there's no life-changing result a
hundred dollars a thousand dollars even
ten thousand dollars
significantly does not significantly
change a person's life enough even if
you're broke you say ten thousand
dollars would change my life forever oh
yeah until you do the math and then
you're like there's no money here
now when you start thinking this big
this is the whole premise of the 10x
rule the 10x rule is not just about big
think the 10x rule is about Necessary
Things the think that is necessary in
order for you to even stay in the game
in the game focused on the goal so
number one the goal has to be meaningful
significant literally life-changing
number two you gotta have daily targets
every day I walk in with a Target I have
a planner and basically what the planner
does is the planner starts off two
sheets of paper
it's got It's got it looks like this
it's a notebook right and this is this
is the right side we start on the right
side this is gulls at the top and this
is targets okay first thing I'm going to
do is I'm gonna write down these
ridiculous targets oh I'm gonna get them
I'm gonna get a a helicopter okay I'm
gonna get a brand new helicopter eight
passenger I got it in my head I got it
mocked up it's black it's got a 10x
underneath it dude it's got Choppers I'm
not doing that this year 10 billion
dollars worth of real estate all this
ridiculous stuff goes here 10 billion
dollars worth of real estate daily
targets you need a daily Target what has
to happen today what what that I can
measure today
in order to stay focused on my goals
tomorrow next week and next month if I
can't pull today off
if I can't pull today off you know in in
uh when you're recovering from drug
addiction it's one day at a time handle
today I used to go to a meeting three
times a day three times a day every day
seven o'clock in the morning one at noon
one at eight o'clock people say luna
that's a lot of that's a lot of meetings
man 21 meetings in one week
but yeah you know what I don't wanna I
don't want to fall off man I got to stay
focused I'm weak the devil's got me the
third thing you got to do and then we'll
open up the phones I need to be held
accountable have an obligation to
someone else I need to publicly tell
people this is what I'm up to I am not
eating meat for seven days
it's not enough to say you're not going
to eat meat for seven days I need
somebody to bring me uh uh the stuff
that's not meat I don't even know what
it is no meat no Dairy no eggs okay so I
need somebody to say hey this is my
obligation this is my commitment I told
Peter Peter make sure I don't want any
meat this week okay everything all
vegetables so when I every couple two or
three hours I need something vegetables
I don't even know where to get this
stuff I need to be I have an obligation
I need to be held accountable I need a
team I need a team to say hey this is
Grant's plan this week I win you win
every time
if I can stay focused long enough to
accomplish one goal one goal
then I can stay focused to accomplish
any goal and Rule Number 10 the last one
before some very special bonus Clips is
handle your money wisely with Jay Shetty
money is something that a lot of us
struggle with to see it clearly is it a
blessing or a curse is it a burden or a
gift we spend years of our life working
for paycheck after paycheck but we
forget to check on if our money is
working for us or if we're just
endlessly working for it
some people have a lot of money but feel
less valued many people don't have
enough money but have a more valuable
life lots of Us come from tough places
financially
and you might be there right now for
some people not having enough money
slows them down
for others the hard times actually helps
to Spur them along to success do you
know how to invest in what you can do
right now money struggles as something
that doesn't just affect us individually
44 of young adults say that money is the
number one stressor in their
relationship it doesn't have hands but
it can still grip us so much of our mind
and so much of ours and our loved ones
time whether you grew up around wealth
or no money at all having a healthy
perspective towards money can either be
the start or the stalling Factor money
can be both a reward but also a
dangerous distractor do you make decent
or even good money but you seem to
always be struggling to pay bills are
you having trouble getting your
financial feet under you maybe your
dreams are trying to run but account
balance just stands still credit card
debt student loans let alone trying to
save it if you want to have more money
try to uncover the ways you wasted
Financial expert sus Allman says if
you're buying coffee every day you may
be literally flushing your chance to be
a millionaire down the drain Allman says
that if you invested the 100 or more per
month that so many of us spend on coffee
into a Roth retirement account instead
over 40 years with compound interest
you'd have a million dollars I could be
wrong but it doesn't take a scholar to
see that is something to consider
another way we waste money is needing
everything brand new or right away
does Amazon help you here and there or
is it a constant part of your everyday
so many decide so fast that they know
what they need so they click and buy now
what if the things you normally buy on
impulse instead sit in your car for a
week
see it after a few days if you actually
need it so you're not impulse buying on
repeat
another way to save money is see what
you can buy used second hand can still
be fantastic and just as easy to do you
could try borrowing from a friend or who
knows giving something in trade
fifteen dollars here and there doesn't
seem like a lot but it can add up
quickly day after day all the time for
us it can be as easy as charging a card
or clicking a button for a digital
payment but at the end of the month are
you settled in your decisions or racking
your mind about where or how to change
them
on Modern conveniences are so amazing
and offer us so much but if you don't
know how to watch your spending your
financial situations may always feel
rough if one of our goals is to work to
live and not live to work then how can
we start to handle our money wisely so
that it's something that helps
and not something that hurts
one way is to uncover the areas where
you may be wasting it where there's New
Perspective that can be new choices new
habits build new ways of making it
making it possible to do the things that
matter and experiencing the things that
will last learn how to invest in the
things that matter learn how to invest
in the things that will last
discipline is your missing ingredient
you've got the heart you've got the care
you've got the desire to serve you know
you could be doing more you want to do
it for the right reasons you're not just
here to make money you're here to have
an impact in the grow and do amazing
things you know you can do amazing
things what's missing discipline
this is a lack of follow-through it's
the constant start and stop and start
and stop and start and stop and
for me there's nothing more
not just frustrating but sad than seeing
somebody who's got so much talent and so
much potential and so much of a heart
and just seeing them not win because
they're not following through because
you're just not doing the consistent
enough work that you're motivated and
inspired and then and then you're not
anymore and nothing happens and one of
the only things that saved me the only
one of the only reason why I'm here
making these videos and you're watching
and I've had any you know success in
social media is because I just was
disciplined that I just kept making
videos one of the things I love sharing
is my journey of YouTube because I was
not an overnight success story
every month almost I'll post my socials
of how I grew month over month year over
year on YouTube and in the first five
years I had 7 000 subscribers or so
five years in five years in of making
content
7 000 subscribers
a lot of you already ahead of that a lot
of you
could get there a lot faster than me
you know how do you keep going when
you're not getting traction when in year
one you have a hundred subscribers
I I just had the discipline to keep
making content to keep following through
and 12 000 videos later here we are
and and people can get there faster you
don't have to be as slow as me you know
I took I took a long time and I had a
lot of issues I was shy and secure and
introverted and felt like you had to be
you know type A personality to win and
all of these all of these limitability
all sorts of issues and you can get
there a lot faster than me but it still
requires a discipline to follow through
and do it and I really think it's one of
the only things that saved me
I remember sitting down at a
um Florida outlet mall and I was sitting
there with uh with a friend and Nina was
going shopping and uh we spent half an
hour at a at a Starbucks there while she
was shopping and he said I'm gonna be
the next garyvee of my mystery it was in
music I'm gonna be the next garyvee in
music
and uh
You're Gonna Keep doing your thing like
let's you know let's let's keep in touch
and see how we do and how we grow and he
posted
you know three or four years later
on his Instagram and he said you know
three or four years three or four years
ago I met Evan Carmichael at this Outlet
Mall in Florida they had our picture as
the as the host and I told him I was
gonna be the next garyvee for music and
he's gonna do keep doing his thing and
and Evan went on and did his thing
and I stopped
I didn't have the success that I said I
was gonna have
and here's the thing this guy has
way more Talent than I do and he's a
super talented in music and just better
camera presence
more energy
uh more his videos just look better way
more attention to detail he had all of
this stuff and and like a warm amazing
human who cares and wants to serve and
wants to see musicians make money and
turn their art into something amazing
right like he had all of this stuff
all of it
the only thing he lack was discipline
and he didn't follow through and and I
see that in so many of you
you've got everything you've got all the
ingredients
that's just a lack of discipline and not
making enough
it's the it's the lack of because you're
not motivated you stop and lack of
motivation isn't a good enough reason
you have to follow through
so how do you do it how do you how do
you uh how do you stay disciplined how
do you stay focused when you're not
getting results when you're not seeing
the wins how do you stay disciplined
okay so let me give you a couple things
first is having a really powerful
morning routine
this is a struggle for entrepreneurs
because no matter how great a day you
had yesterday today is a new day no
matter how great today is tomorrow's a
new day it's like you're starting over
every day you go to an event or you
watch a video get all inspired and you
expect it to last and then tomorrow you
wake up it's like oh how come I don't
feel the same way as I did yesterday and
then that creates a cycle of
procrastination instead of actually
following through so the morning routine
really matters what is it that gets you
feel inspired motivated creative ready
to go so that you go off and have a much
better day for me
two of the things that I find the most
valuable are in my morning routine one
is music so I put on music right away
it's the fastest way to change your
state put on songs that make you move
that make you dance and make you wanna
just change your state because you wake
up tired and no energy like let's go we
gotta demand Excellence from ourselves
and so music is the fastest way to get
your body into a different state
um
and the second in my morning routine is
to do a believe walk and that's 20
minutes to an hour every day I walk I go
to Tim Hortons I grab a cup of coffee
and spend you know two bucks on it and I
think about my day how do I want my day
to go but how do I want to be
intentional about the day so we're not
waking up like an accident most people
wake up like an accident fall into their
day look at other people load your phone
you write other people's agenda for your
time and then you don't follow through
and so having that is part of my morning
routine really helps me so what is your
morning routine the most important thing
that you need to do is the thing that
makes you feel important vibrant that
today's gonna matter
put that into your morning routine
instead of hoping that it happened
that's why I make so many videos too
there's content for you every day if you
need me in your life or you need the
people that I profoundly there's
something every single day for you
across my channels so there's no excuse
for you not to get the the inspiration
and the motivation and the tactics that
you need to make your dreams happen so
that's step number one is have have a
powerful morning routine step number two
is create a calendar you know what's in
your calendar I'm making videos today
because it's in my calendar today's a
Tuesday when I'm recording this and
Tuesday is my YouTube day
there's a lot of stuff happening in my
life there's a lot of stuff happening in
my business uh you know right now we're
at um my my wife's parents house and
they're delivering a couch
see that delivering a couch here
it's a delivering a couch and they're
helping I'm here making content because
Tuesday is my YouTube day you know
there's so many other things I could be
doing right now
if I was left to my own devices I'd say
I have something more important to do I
need to be doing X
but because this has been scheduled in
my calendar I'm going to follow through
and make videos
how have I made you know 12 000 videos
because it's in my calendar it's been in
my calendar for years to make videos
so create a calendar especially with the
things that you know you need to do that
you're afraid to do I'm still afraid to
make videos guys you know again 12 000
videos later I'm still afraid to make
videos why because I want these videos
to be the best I've ever done because I
want to show up with more care more
heart more passion I hope that this is a
video that forces you you know to take
some kind of action I wanted to be the
best one that I've done and so I I'm
mini procrastinate before making videos
on a Tuesday every week I have a mini
mini procrastination the only difference
is my procrastination is you know 10
minutes instead of days 10 days and then
it doesn't happen right and so whatever
you are procrastinating on that you know
is important that you're just afraid of
you put in your calendar and you block
off time and that allows you the
creativity and the space and suffocates
the excuses
for you not to follow through and then
step number three so one have a morning
routine right that sets you up it
creates that gets you inspired makes you
feel like you're important today's gonna
matter two you create a schedule for
when you're gonna do the things
especially the scary things on your list
and then three you have to teach
yourself that you do the things that are
in your calendar
you said you're gonna do it you put in
your calendar you get it done even if
you're tired even if you feel
overwhelmed you can change your calendar
for tomorrow or you can change your
calendar for next week
but don't trust yourself or listen to
yourself when you're feeling low when
you're feeling overwhelmed and you said
you were gonna do it
you have to go up and do it to teach
yourself because what happens is the
next time you say you're going to do
something you put in your calendar you
don't trust it you're going to follow
through because you haven't followed
through the last 20 times
so be very careful about what you put
into your calendar I know when it's in
there you have to go off and do it
make those three changes in your life
morning routine
create a schedule do what's in your
schedule
the only thing you're missing is
discipline again you've got the heart
you've got the creativity you've got the
passion you've got the willingness to
serve you know you can do more you want
to create an amazing life for yourself
your family the people around you like
you know you've got this thing is you
know you've got this thing I don't need
to tell you this you know that you've
got something amazing inside you
and yet it's not happening consistently
enough you have to stop jumping from
high to high to high and and wondering
why you don't feel motivated today
there's nothing wrong with you this is
normal foreign
discipline
put it into your life and watch your
entire life change
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to see how
Jamie Kern Lima turned a thousand
dollars into 1.2 billion check the video
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe and I'll see
you there I think our gut is always
stronger than anyone else's advice and
our gut will tell us what the right
advice is to listen to oh this is what
Jamie did when someone said no